Okay, welcome everyone and welcome Greg Salano Gargad. It is our first actual guest lecture.
We had Ellie in the class session, but we have a first guest visiting the course today.
And super excited about this. He is one of the co-founders of Yuga Labs. Yuga Labs today has a fairly
dominant position in the PFP area. And so I think there's going to be a lot of really interesting
things we can discuss starting with some basics and then getting more complicated. But first,
let me welcome Greg to the course. Thank you so much for having me 6529 and thanks to the
University of Nicosia for hosting this course. I think it's super cool. It's a really
exciting way for people to get exposure to a lot of different metaverse thought leaders. I'm
personally excited about a lot of people you have slated to speak later in the semester as it were.
Greg, well let's jump right in and I think for our audience is mixed. I think we have people in
the audience who are absolute NFT gurus and people who are NFT novices. So I'll try and cover
things that will be helpful to both. Let's start at the beginning. How did Yuga Labs, how did the
Bored Ape Yacht Cub, how did it come about? Sure. I think to tell that story, it probably helps to tell
how I was first exposed to crypto. Like a lot of people the first time I heard about Bitcoin in
perhaps 2010, 2011. I wasn't, I was somewhat dismissive at first. I saw it as just this, yeah,
magic internet money was how it was talked about in those early days, right? And it didn't really
capture my attention. But in 2017, I first bought into Ethereum and I immediately called a friend of mine
while I was here now, aka Gordon Connor and had him get in on, it's a crypto with me. And we fell
into this whole world very quickly. We spent a lot of time on crypto Twitter following all these
different personalities that were around. A lot of them, you know, still very active to this day,
Kobe, Lundar, you know, a lot of different folks that that have been kind of mainstays in this
space. And it was so exciting, you know, it really felt like crypto engaged our attention like almost
nothing else. Why me and I in particular would spend a lot of our time hanging out in digital spaces,
playing World of Warcraft or other different MMORPGs, massive multiplayer online role playing games
together and weirdly our session with crypto ran very much in parallel with it. It was a parallel
passion. And in those days, I was exposed to crypto kitties. And it was fascinating. I didn't
actually buy a cryptocurrency at the time in 2017-2018 that area while we did. But I fell into NFTs
later more deeply in 2021. There were a slew of different projects that all of a sudden felt like
they were using the blockchain to as more of a medium than anything else. It wasn't, you know,
crypto kitties was at its core of a game and an experience. But then when you had hash mass,
which was kind of this arc project that was using Ethereum as a medium and you had people
selling an NFT for an extraordinary camera price at Christie's, you really started to feel like
this is something where this is a new medium opening up in the same way that anything, you know,
podcasts opened up to the world 10 years before. And if you could be early to that and if you could
be one of the first people to join in and tell stories on a platform and understand how communities
would form around it and engage with things and what would succeed, what would be viral, it would be fun.
There's a lot of power to that because my background was in creative writing. I was a book editor
for 10 years. I was a poet. And so why didn't I really just were off to the races trying to
understand what kind of NFT project we could create? We've looped in our other two founders
tomato and sass aka primanzishan for the engineering part of things. And we spent some months
playing around with all kinds of ideas. But in the end, what we settled on was we wanted to make a
an NFT collection, a similar in spirit to CryptoPunks, Matt and John's CryptoPunks that obviously
have 10,000 NFTs, unique PFCs. But we wanted there to be some inherent utility to the token.
We wanted it to be something that you could, you know, the prime thing that we were interested in
from the beginning was NFTs as something that, you know, having a great use space for two things.
Authenticity and scarcity. And earlier on with CryptoKitties, those two things kind of got a little
out of whack with the breeding mechanics. There was too much supply, felt dilutive. But with the wave
of projects coming prominence and the kind of rediscovery or celebration of CryptoPunks that
was happening in 2021, it was really about the idea of knowing that you had this immutable NFT
on the blockchain, and there was only X number of them, the prominence of that. And so we came up with
the idea of Bored Ape Yacht Club. And the inherent utility of the token was going to be that if you
owned a BAYC, that you were going to be part of a club. And what that club met at the beginning
was just that you were among like-minded people, hopefully, but also that you got access to a
digital pixel board, a little space on our website, cryptographically verified that you could use
your token to get access to the, quote, bathroom and, you know, graffiti on the wall. And if you
own a BAYC, you could put a pixel down every 15 minutes. And so the bathroom would be kind of
this palmsest of people writing to this wall in collaboration with one another. And that was
the initial thing. And as far as the spirit of what Bordeic meant to us early on, we really saw
a lot of the early influencers and people in the space that we followed for years as Bordeics.
You know, an ape is an affectionate term in crypto and in trading circles for people who dive
first into an asset or kind of throw caution to the wind. There's a reason why some of the most
valuable apes in the crypto punk, some, why some of the most valuable NFTs in the crypto punk
collection are apes. And so we thought it'd be really cool to make an entire collection, an
entire NFT project that was just about the apes. But also that it didn't necessarily take itself
too seriously. There are people on crypto Twitter that you can cryptographically verify or
worth incredible sums of money. Yet they are spending their days shit-posting, you know, making jokes,
looking for people to play League of Legends with. They were in every way to us like Bordeics. And
so we started to imagine like what a this kind of fanciful, irreverent, strange world of the Bordeic
yacht club might look like. And we said it in our hometown of Miami. We said it in the Everglades.
And yeah, the rest is history. So let's talk about that. I remember the early days when you
launched. The the start didn't look shockingly promising. Like the mint didn't mint out right
away. It took several days. And so it's now have generated maximum coping from every one of us who
didn't go and mint a lot of Bordeics during that period. I think I bought one the week afterwards
or something. And okay, it was another PFP project that didn't mint out for several days.
And there was the Boughton board as you say. And when saying, oh, I wonder who's going to draw
genitals on the Boughton board, right? But from there to where we are today is kind of a shocking
difference, right? So let me put it differently. If you saw the project on day 10,
you could imagine a lot of projects like that on day 10, most of which have not had the success
or even a fractional success that the project is at. What do you attribute to the fact that
it started, you know, normally fun, silly, but didn't seem too serious. And suddenly it just
built up this life of its own and turned into what it turned into. What in your mind was that
magic, the secret sauce, the magic formula? What did it? Yeah, I attributed to a few things.
Number one, we tried to set up the incentive structure in a little bit different way
than a lot of things that had come out at the same time or just before the UIC.
So you had a series of different projects that were following the formula where each mint
would cost, you know, first X amount of been saved, thousand, cost a certain price.
And then the next thousand more and then the next thousand more until in the end the collection
is sold out. But that leaves you with holders that all have different entry prices into this.
And then it kind of felt inherently disuniting. It wasn't exactly welcoming when you would
join a discord and know that the guy next to you paid on the same website from the same
mentor for the primary sale, the different costs. It felt like something that would help sell
out a project, but not necessarily be healthy to the sustainability of the project.
Obviously, crypto punks were a free claim and, you know, completely different.
But at the time when we were minting in 2021, most projects in the space were following
this other model. So that was one of the things we did. We said every eight should cost 0.08,
218 bucks or something like that is what it was at the time. And we tried very hard to
push a sense of welcoming into our discord. Anytime somebody would join,
we wanted there to be a stream of all caps welcome there. We wanted
the founders to be available for any issues people are having. If people meet it to DM us and
ask us questions, we were around. And I think there was a bit of magic in that
NBA top shot had just exposed a lot of new people to entities. And we found around the time
of the BOIC mint. A lot of those people, we were their first kind of Ethereum entity.
And there was a lot of excitement to that. There was a lot of people, you know, we had built
this project seemingly hoping for a lot of crypto native people to be exposed. When in fact,
what ended up happening was a lot of people who'd kind of put a toe into this base. Yes,
they bought something off coin base before or they had experimented with NBA top shots or
otherwise. But we were the first thing to kind of bring them into setting up a Metamask wallet
and getting involved in a community. And capturing that kind of organic energy from the start
and having those people so excited and finding each other. And as a reminder too, we were in
COVID. So just finding friends and engagement and having a good time on Discord is a really
powerful thing just from the start. That helped a lot. And I think also we, frankly as the founders,
we sold out the collection and then we worked 14 hours a day ever since to not take that moment
for granted and try and create new experiences in any way that we could. And I think
you know, when we were doing token gated merch, say a month later and boxing up T-shirts and hats
that we sold and we were boxing up in my mom's backyard. Yes, there had been token gated
merch before. Obviously the most famous of which would be unisocks of, you know, if you own
the token, you could redeem it for actual socks. But it wasn't necessarily a community or felt
like something that could be its own lifestyle brand. And the other aspect I think that was really
powerful the whole way through is we gave all of our holders commercial rights to their aid. And
that sense of having a stake in the project being part of the community and having it tied to your
online identity that was really powerful and led to a lot of projects and ingenuity and creativity
in a bottoms up way throughout the space where we had Jenkins de Valet very early on getting signed
to CAA and developing an entire, his own entire project, you know, really starting with his
eighth and the story that he was telling and telling other, you know, community member stories.
And we've now seen everything from animated TV shows that are in development to people
watching clothing brands, sometimes very simple streetwear, other times as incredible as like,
you know, $500, like cashmere, exquisite cashmere cardigans being sold at like Fred Segal.
And that's been really special. Yeah, that was a bit long-winded, but I think that covers
broadly speaking a lot of what I think I attribute our success to.
No, it sounds reasonable and I will say I think, you know, there was also a feeling,
maybe I'm reading this from the outside, but like there were people who
viewed themselves as the upstart rebels relative to the punks in some capacity, right? Like it was
the New York cohort, more fun, more irreverent, something in that direction. But I want to build on
this commercial rights issue because that had had a lot of follow-on effects in the space.
I think massive follow-on effects. I mean, if I think of the thing that probably changed the
space the most, it's this. And let's dig into it a little bit. How is that going now, right?
And then what I mean by this is the following. In the early days, you absolutely saw the initial
activity, right? Someone would do a DJ set and use their or dates or a coffee brand or a microgroup.
And certain people signed, as you said, to agencies. There was the group that was the music group
that was signed. First question, how is that going today a year and a half later? Are these
things that still developing? Do you have any metrics to track them? Is there, are people sticking to
it? Because some of the kind of the blow in the bear case on community commercial rights is
the blue case is obvious. You'll get 10,000 people working to promote the rent. The bear case is
probably most of those people don't actually have the capacity or capability to build
a viable business because building businesses is hard. In any case, not just in this case.
How do you think about it? How do you manage it? How do you track it? What does success look like?
How do you think about the software? Yeah, I think to start with the idea behind it,
why it made sense to us was if this token of this BAYC cryptographically verified on the blockchain
by owning one, we wanted it to be your digital identity in any way you solve it,
that it would make sense to us to make sure that you had unlimited commercial rights to that thing
so that if you wanted to appear as your Bordeic in sandbox or in decentralized or in other side
or in any other kind of metaverse space, you could do that. You wouldn't have to ask permission.
The optionality of that whole experience is the most important part of it to me.
Yes, there are people who, there have been people that have expanded a tremendous amount of
effort or are extremely talented and are building incredible things with their BAYCs.
There's the Borden Hungry fast food restaurant, there's Dr. von Bees,
Snoop Dogg's alter ego BAYC that appears with them seemingly on stage all the time these days.
There's casual sweaters being sold at some of the most revered shops in the world,
you know, shops in the world like Fred Siegel and there's different animated shows,
some that are still in development and some more web-3 native versions that are going to be coming
out that we're aware of. How do we measure it? How do we track it? I don't know the best answer
to that. The whole idea is that it's a permissionless system and that we don't necessarily need to.
If these things are able to spread up and do spread up without us, then it's doing its job.
And as long as people don't feel like there are blockers towards their
creativity and that's what's most important from our perspective. I don't know if that answers
your question. No, I think that's clear. I'll say it back in my words, if someone's going to make
their identity, this PFP their identity, well, they should be able to do whatever they want with it,
right? They don't have to go ask someone permission and then there's a normal 80, 20, or 90, 10,
or 95, 5 outcome was a few people will do it off a lot of things and most people won't do very much
but even if they don't do very much, it's valuable. The idea is valuable even if you don't actually
start a merchandise shop or a fast food restaurant a day by your board. Is that a fair assessment?
That's a great summary. Yeah. Okay. In that world, let's build on that. What do you see
the role of the company and the role of the network in what comes over one year, three years, ten years?
What do you do now? Because you know, you're now getting into much more verified territory.
Going from one million to ten million, one thing and ten million to a hundred million is another
thing. Now whether you look at the market cap of all your tokens or the equity value of the firm,
generally, we're talking billions. So now this is now moving forward at that level.
There's a different game than a third level. Who does what? How do they do it? How do you think about it?
What are the goals? How do I think about this stuff? Yeah. So I think there's a couple different
questions that I hear there. Number one, yes, you guys experienced exponential growth over the past
year and a half. In January of this year, we were 11 people today. We're 85 and we'll almost certainly
be over a hundred before the end of the year. And part of that is having several different teams,
but the ones that are most built out on the BAYC team and the other side team, that are constantly
working on projects of vastly different scale. Some things might be as small as a merch shop
for B O I C. And then there might be projects that have literally, you know, a year plus long
time span until lunch. And as we approach what we want to do, though, as we think of BAYC say,
what is a Web 3 lifestyle brand? Look like a Web 3 club. Look like there's things we've talked
about like having a in real life clubhouse here in Miami where people can get together in the
vein, perhaps, of something like so house or ZZ's or some of these amazing membership clubs that
exist. That's one thing. And there's a lot of different aspects of what we're building with B O I
C. But I'd say the most consistent question in this time and your question about commercial rights
and what users do is how do we do things in a way that's a value add and doesn't say in
pin John or step on anyone's toes. Right now, there's several different animated series that I
know of where people are either we're using at least one word as a character in a show or something
like that. That's awesome. If we were to come out and do, you know, our own BAYC show and
not incorporate the community then that hurts those people who are going out and doing, you know,
trying to tell their stories. So how can we structure our business, what we're doing as a company
in a way where we're creating sandboxes for other people to build together and enjoy the
commercial rights and connect with one another and all those sorts of things rather than doing things
that are redundant or duplicative or taking over things that really should be more on the community
level than otherwise. Okay, that makes sense. You mentioned twice lifestyle company, right?
What does that mean to you? Early on, we thought of this idea of like what would a Web 3
Supreme look like. There's what's it's been very interesting over the past year and a half
as NFTs have gone more and more into the mainstream how different legacy companies or
industries have have taken or not to Web 3. There's a lot of game companies that are very actively
tripling in companies that are very actively building, exploring, enjoying, you know, the fruits
of a Web 3 division. However, there's a lot of gamers who are more reticent towards games,
towards blockchain gaming. There's a number of different reasons and thoughts on that we can get
into that later. On the other hand, you have companies like LVMH and the caring group behind
Gucci and Valenciaga and so many different major brands who seem to very much be leaning into
Web 3. They're thinking about, hey, here's this protocol layer tool, this tech that we can use
that is all about digital scarcity and authenticity. And they have these companies that that's
the red and butter is creating a brand and maintaining a strict level of scarcity and authenticity.
And I think for that reason, we're going to see an explosion of more and more interest from that
that whole sector. And that was something that we thought about very early on with BAUIC,
where I'm like crypto punks where the punks themselves are kind of the low. There was no crypto
punks logo per se. There is that kind of beautiful hot pink that they picked for the website,
but it wasn't really like a Nike swoosh or something like that. Whereas for BAYC,
we were very cognizant of, hey, we want there to be a logo here, we want there to be a story,
we want there to be more for people to launch off of and generate stories from and content from
in a way where constraints and storytelling can be generative and not that we're like saying
strict canon and that's all there is to the story. So navigating that those lines was always
really important to us. And so, yeah, we wanted the BAYC school to be our Nike swoosh and what
does that mean in a Web 3 space? I think there's a lot of potential there. I mean, just seeing that
Azuki is releasing there a new physical token standard. That's just awesome. I think we're going to see
a lot more experiments in this space. I think it's very natural for NFT company to be
diving and thinking of itself as a lifestyle brand. So, here's a question that I go back and
I think I thought about it a reasonable note. You have 30,000 PFP token holders, right? Let's leave
the punks out for a second. All right. So, the board apes and the mutant apes. And there's the code
is that I think are part of the game and are not exactly PFPs. We'll discover that, but that
even if we put those in, it's another 10,000. So, 40,000. Rolex, which is thought of as a fairly
exclusive brand, sells a million Rolexes a year. Nike, much of the swoosh, sells 800 million shoes,
pairs of shoes a year. So, Nike is of course a global brand and hundreds of millions of people
are part of that brand. Even Rolex, it's almost a code word for, I mean, not
update luxury, but luxury exclusive. Millions, tens of millions of people own a Rolex or part of the
Rolex community. Your community is 40,000 people, right? And that's closer to a superhyper elite
sub-brand of old VH or something like a Soho House, you know, 30 to 40,000 people is a very, very
elite brand. But I would say the aesthetic of, or it is more fun, less, this is a Swiss watch
that you're going to hand out, hand down to 11 generations and build a whole wing of your house
to put it in, right? I give it, neither one's right wrong. It's just the aesthetic that comes out.
And so, if these are somehow comparable, I don't know the numbers off hand for supreme, but I
think supreme sells a reasonable amount of goods or a reasonable amount of people on an ongoing
basis. How does this play out? Does the community need to grow? Do you become hyper elite? Is it
going to be, you know, Soho House is a lifestyle brand and Nike is a lifestyle brand, but Soho House
is a lifestyle brand that you need thousands of dollars to get into. And Nike is a lifestyle brand,
you need like, I don't know, 40 bucks to get into. How does this play out? Yeah, obviously it's a
question that a lot of people have been asking ever since this new wave of NFT collections have
come out and attained valuations that are massive. And on par with some of these companies that
are, we're far exceeding some of these companies that seem to have way more users. I will say,
I think there's a difference between owning BAYC for me being part of a club, let's say. And other
ways to experience things and have exposure to BAYC as a brand. And I think as we onboard,
more and more people into Web 3, there is going to be much more opportunities for things like
that to happen in a way that are not dilutive necessarily to the BAYC club members, you know,
the people who own the 10,000 BAYC, 20,000 mutants, but still provide, say, a tiering of access
to people to buy a BAYC t-shirt. One of our most successful merch shops all time was when we
did a drop with a collab with the hundreds. And there was a public sale colorway where anyone can
buy this logo mashup of the BAYC and 100s logo on the hundreds website. And I think we'll see
a lot more of that. We'll see a lot more of co-labs and ways for people to participate in the space,
while still maintaining the exclusivity of the club as it stands today. That feels that's very
important to us. I think it's an unfortunate aspect of some early NFT projects where breeding
mechanics got totally out of hand and felt more akin to a free-to-play model where
you're constantly having to devalue the original thing in order to gain a customer acquisition.
I think there is a much more thoughtful and sustainable model attainable where you treat it,
like I said, more like a brand and you're not constantly expanding the club or anything like that.
Well, it's interesting you mentioned free-to-play because this has now gotten
hot again with Gabriel Layden's Digi Di-Gruz, and it's getting a lot of attention.
It's not 100% clear to me how that's different than other things that happen in that
NFT space because I mean, the air drop might be free, but I went and bought a Digi Di-Gruz
by everything. Oh, my one of everything just to see how I feel when I heard it.
And it certainly wasn't free when I bought it. I think I paid 50 needs, so I mean, it wasn't,
I doubt I'll be playing whatever game's going to be there, but it certainly wasn't free for me to
play it. I had to buy it on the secondary market in OpenSea. What does free-to-play even mean in
the context of NFTs? I mean, there's a robust secondary market in these characters and it's not
at all free and how do we think about that? Yeah, I think about free-to-play more in a sense of,
you know, there's been a lot of innovations in gaming over the past 20 years that the industry
has changed all the time. I've never worked in gaming, but I've written books on video games
and you know, been an avid gamer my whole life. And what I think about is the different ways
where game companies have tried to structure incentives or subscription models to
acquire new users. And so you have something I think a lot about, for example, as it pertains to, and a
tease, and the future of watching gaming is Dota AllStars. Dota All-Stars was a MOBA, so a genre of
video game that now, you know, we look at League of Legends and it's one of the most popular engaging
video games in the world. And I think I'll cryptate Twitter like the most popular video game in the world,
probably. But it really started out as this Warcraft 3 mod, this custom game mode,
called Dota All-Stars, where a user with a pseudonym, IceRog, I believe it was, and I think there
were some other people involved too, created a game using a open-source map maker of sorts,
where Warcraft 3 said, hey, if you can use our graphics, our characters, the rigs, and the map
mode, and make a game and enjoy yourselves. Have fun. Yet Warcraft 3 had no subscription model.
They weren't making money, they were making 10 bucks a month like they do on Warcraft or something
like that, or 15. And IceRog had seemingly no in-platform way to monetize this either. And so you
had this setup where you had arguably one of the most popular games in the world, and nobody was
really making money directly off of it, until somebody took the learnings of this genre,
adapt it, and classed them up, professionalized them, and released League of Legends, which,
you know, and the rest of their history. And now you have a game that makes a couple billion
dollars a year, I think, selling skin, selling cosmetics that would have on a database.
So one, and that's the free-to-play model. You know, League of Legends now, they make incredible
amounts of money on skins, so does Fortnite, Fortnite makes double triple the amount that they do,
I think. And obviously, these are just cosmetic characters, they're fun, they're your digital avatar
in the game. You can send the friends, I think, sometimes, but oftentimes not. But you don't
know, maybe truly own these things. And then you also have a whole lot of, quote, free-to-play
or games that exist on the app store. People spend over a hundred billion dollars a year on the
app store, buying digital assets for games. And the way that those games work is you have to keep
buying a certain item. You'll finally show up to buy it. But seemingly, the next season,
there's something that's even better, and then you're showing up again and again. And with the
statistics show us about those games, it's about 8% of the people playing them are accounting for
like 90 something percent of the revenue of these games. It's a very like whale-driven market.
And so, when I think about the opportunity for what Gabriel's calling
played at own or just in general watching gaming, it's the idea of how do we create
an incentive structure where the next time somebody is creating a game on top of a platform
the way Dota AllStars is made on top of Warcraft III, that the content creator doesn't need to go
off and where the person doing this doesn't have to go off and I create a YouTube channel
or a Patreon or something else in order to monetize the development. That the idea that these
things are entities at their core means that the ownership and the treatability and the access
and a lot more crypto-native things here will make the value grow much smoother and so that you don't
have another company popping up and sucking out all of that. And I agree, I don't know that like
that the whole play to own thing is a free to own thing is a bit of a meme here and that there's
been a lot of things that have functioned in this way but what I'm just excited about is the idea
of games where there's the inherent openness and interoperability of NFTs and what that opens up
for gaming across different platforms where no longer if there's that authenticity and scarcity
inherent NFTs and it's in a game then it feels like the traditional free to play some cost systems
where you're constantly developing the previous thing maybe don't need to happen if there is
a value of rule that can happen as opposed on like you say a platform royalty level or something
like that. Okay well you mentioned royalties it was on my to-do list so let's jump into it.
There has now I'm going to do a little background for the audience. I think through the first
couple of years of NFTs one of the things that was been promoted as a positive feature particularly
for artists is that they would earn secondary royalties and by what this means is royalties
on someone selling their NFTs to someone else. So a primary sale is when it sold by the
artist or the project creator to the user and the secondary sale is when that user sells it further
out and this was promoted both as a boon to artists who might in the beginning be less well-known
and might sell their work inexpensively but then they become successful and somehow they share
in the success and it has been very effective for the large and successful projects. I mean the
initial airdrop did not fund you go labs very much money but because the collection became
very popular and traded a lot it generated a very large income stream of royalties and this
was let's say state of the world until three to six months ago three to six months ago a lot of
folks from in my view the fungible claim world looked at royalties and said oh my this is transaction
tax in a really high one it's two and a half percent or five percent or ten percent
and this is not so we couldn't imagine like Solana or sushi or B&B taking five or ten percent
of your B&B every time you sell it. This is crazy and we're in a permissionless blockchain of course
the blockchain is going to route around these taxes because there's always a way technically to
run it around them and it started a process of one exchange uh said well I'm not going to
auto royalties or make them optional and you know I remember saying at the time I mean that's
clearly not a sustainable business model for them because if it works all the changes you're
going to do it um and now there's this very active debate where let's say one team
believes that the NFT project creators and artists are being hopelessly naive in expecting that
this type of royalty amounts could remain attached to the surface and the other side
says well this is not the deal we signed up for I'm a photographer I sold you this NFT with these
terms and you're just violating them and I mean some of the more extreme reactions and I'm okay
you can sell it for no royalties but then change the metadata on a contract where the metadata
is not frozen and then you would have that if they were this was we had a deal this was a contract
we had a deal and and then kind of the third point of view which at least I think more intellectually
honest than the first point of view as well other artists will come out compete to artists who
want royalties by offering their work without royalties to me I think that's more intellectually
honest than people who want to change the rules of the game and then you know there's other
people sometimes like well we should keep it for artists but you know big projects like you
know they've made a lot of money they don't need them they'll sell t-shirts or access to the club
or other drops and on the fifth hand then I'm going to stop or if you'll say well you're just
going to incent project creators to dilute your initial NFTs because if they're not can't make any
money off the secondary market they'll just do more drops which might be fine for them but might
not be so great for you so be careful what you wish for and we're in this I think calm before
the storm to be honest state right what's your view on this A how do you see it playing out B
does it is it different for a pfp community for an artist and I guess where do you think we'll
settle out in one two five years on the stop so I'll start with the caveat that I'm not so much
of a futurist as has yourself in in thinking about the long term arc of you know playing out how
some of these things might resolve over the course of say five years I will say from the very
beginning it's been interesting how of all the different people coming into this space from
different industries let's say some of the most engaged very early on people who came from
the music industry which is an industry where people feel where creators have gotten often feel
like the creators have gotten to rock you my partner Gio series partner here at Yuga that's
certainly what interested him about the NFT space is here it is a world where creators can have
a smart contract on day one on their terms and not wait until you know whereas a lot of musicians
they don't they don't have a great contract day one they work their way up to it with help
the managers and agents and all this stuff over time and so that there's that power to the idea
of creator royalties and how easy they were for a while there to set up across the space was
really powerful so that said we've always known that creator royalties were something that you could
get around you know the way it functions or those who don't know obviously is it's essentially a
fee that's getting paid to you by the platform not inherent to the smart contract itself so like
as if eBay or stock X decided to send a little bit of money to Nike every time somebody bought
a pair of air Jordans on on their platform and for a long time it's been extremely useful I think
in directing liquidity and value and creators promoting marketplaces as opposed to others
I think the way that this is playing out currently is very interesting I think in part it is a
reaction to marketplace fees being too high I think in part you know a lot of the trading that's
happened in the past years happened by people that knew perfectly well they could have gotten
around the royalties should they have chosen to it's things like NFT trader have been around since
basically since since foray minted as far as I know and yet we've seen a lot of people
decide that they want to pay the royalty either the buyers want to make sure that that's
incorporated or to sell it to you and I think there's a lot of power to that number one I think the
idea where creators or artists may get out competed by others who don't seek a royalty is
interesting I don't quite see it that way I think the idea of creator royalties has pushed a lot of
creativity and ingenuity and like just frankly it's made the creative investment into the space
that much more rewarding and so brought a lot of people into it if the royalties hadn't existed
I don't think there's any way we would have seen the explosion that we've seen over the past year
and a half with different people entering this space that said having a you know censorship
censorship resistance immutable tokens that's important an extremely important aspect to entities
and it's been kind of funny to see this playing out on both sides
certain marketplaces coming out against royalties we're saying that they're not going to honor them
but then also seemingly reacting quite aggressive when a digital artist releases a new smart
contract a new NFT and smart contract explicitly prohibits set marketplace so I think there's
going to be quite a bit of gamesmanship a bit of a chess game going on here for the next couple
months we certainly have a lot of different ideas internally that we are kicking around about
this issue and how best to preserve the creative energy that's been and champion artist rights
and also do it in a way where you maintain the what an NFT really needs to be in the openness
and interoperability and censorship resistance that is integral to what we're talking about here
it would seem to me that in the boarding universe you do have leveraged I'm not saying
to get any music but you have leveraged because you do so many off-chain events and utility and
what have you and you wouldn't you could I had written a thread on royalties and actually in my
mind how the board apes and the punks could address royalties is different right because let's say
there were royalties on the punks I think most bunk holders wouldn't particularly
feel they'd lose anything if they went around right but on a board apel there you could say
look if you trade it on this zero royalty exchange maybe next year you can't come to ape fest or
you can't get into the clubhouse for six months or you have to pay your royalty to get back into
the clubhouse now no this might be annoying and not to branding and I'm not saying it's a good
business idea but it is a form of leverage that a project that has off-chain activities has
that a project that does not really have off-chain activities doesn't have has this ever been considered
discussed thought about at the same time I think there's a because of so many things that you get
does I think a lot of people have been happy to pay the royalty and I would much rather run my
business with a carrot than a stick and so I don't love the idea you know of course we we talk
about all kinds of things but I always want to think about how can I make this the most engaging
fun strange cool club in the world and have people be so excited to be a part of it then
if you're coming at it from a defensive position I feel like that's an inherently weak one
when it comes to a permissionless space and that's where you can frankly I think get out-computed
so it's just about trying to find the right how can you create an optimistic incentive structure
rather than a same negative one or a defensive one okay so you're landing basically in the
people ex copy category of saying you know we're not going to harass our collectors obviously
it's a social contract and you kind of want to build a collector base that wants to pay the
royalties that it's a social thing not a technical thing right in the end and it's a positive
they're getting enough value out of this that they're not going to try and work around it
because they see value in the community something like that something like that I mean I
honestly don't speak for you know all of you go and we have a lot of different ideas that you
know everyone's kicking around and enjoying and and and I think the other important thing here is
this is a very new space there's a lot of discussions around this whole thing going on
on crypto twitter right now and it'll be interesting to see how it plays out but but that's
absolutely correct I would put myself more in the the people ex copy camp of how do we just you
know worry about your community and how you can best service them and your collectors and a lot
of this other part will fall away without you needing to be draconian in in anyway
okay let's talk about cc zero for a second in a few days I'm going to talk to four one five six
founded the nouns pfp project where that project is in the public delayed it's cc creative
common zero it has no royalties the money goes to some somewhat fuzzy in my mind form of treasury
when it goes to treasury and in a way it's a very extreme version of what you had said previously
so previously to put some words in rather than 30,000 holders of 40,000 and they have
they're the core community but someone else who might not own a
or a pfp might buy a board a t-shirt right there's a broader ecosystem around it and
I would say the nouns are this very explicitly and more extreme right there's only one a day
you know even though I don't know 30,000 PFPs are not a lot I don't think they're a lot because
I want to onboard a hundred million people so not a lot the nouns are even more extreme it's
going to take 82 years for there to be 30,000 nouns but then what the nouns say is not only
a nouns holder can do whatever they want with their pfp identity so can anyone else and effectively
what they're saying and I think what 4156 will say later in the week is we're going to start off
slow because it's a slow model but eventually we're going to just pick up pure network effects
that someone in you know you'll go might be doing 50 things or 30 things but they'll have to do
them whereas when we've gone completely permissionless there'll be someone in Japan doing
something we'll even know about it then someone in Italy doing something and if the flywheel
picks up and the nouns glasses become the equivalent of the 40 logo that the now the an open
source brand is to be very successful and I think I mean putting words in his mouth so we'll
find out later in the week is what he says but it's how to understand from a stutter feed
what are your views on this how do these two models compete coexist is one better than
the other does we not know yet um I think they certainly coexist I think um both of these things
are are very new um and I think it's just it's a different model whereas we're of the opinion
or have structured our club in this way where set another way only a board eight the the
rights to use a board eight and and put it on a t-shirt is not in itself inherently extremely
valuable but what is valuable is if the club becomes a space more and more as it frankly has been
for a while where a lot of people are spending an enormous amount of effort in order to develop
the IP of their avatar of their creator and where cco and and this commercial rights debate I think
shakes out is the idea of we're wondering who is more incentivized to build and build in a like
long term thought the long term thoughtful way um somebody who owns something and um has that
true ownership to the IP and so perhaps feels more comfortable or engaged to build on top of it
or this very open source model that nouns is pursuing um and I don't know that there that you
know there needs to be a winner and a loser I think they're inherently very different I think
number one the amount of storytelling and engagement and things that we're doing on the
Hugo level for our brands particularly BAYC and other side is very different than what 4156 would
do or frankly want to do with nouns like they're they're trying to create something very different
um at the same time the kinds of value accrual to people who create on top of either platform I
think are going to be very different and how that shakes out is kind of remains to be seen
uh a bit as as the model that they've taken like like he like I think he would agree just
it's going to take longer to see whether or not it's truly um working as intended or not
and I think but he's a very thoughtful person and is excited I think about the experimentation
and the testing uh I think I was saying that they're planning on deleting their discord
I saw that yeah that's um I don't I don't think we we'd ever be able to do that
yeah is it is it fair to say you can go on record saying you're not planning to delete
the board apes discord that's correct you know not until we've got a better replacement
okay I think that's one more question about board apes and if you have time to extend I want to
talk about punks another side a little bit too do you have a little bit of time to extend
share yeah okay so I think largely due to board apes prominence in this space you also attract a lot
of backlash in different time now mention two things that one that really surprised me one that
doesn't surprise me as much a few weeks ago I was having an extensive back and forth with
mirage of coin center and I was like you know about how they could promote NFTs you know
you just want you just wanted to promote ENS I mean I'm putting words in his mouth but kind of
and it's not that the ENS is very nice and very useful you should promote it but I mean
TFPs are like the absolute most obvious product market fit for the metaverse where the metaverse
is going to be I mean you're going to need a profile picture you'll need an avatar and there was a
very negative reaction from him he's like no no no no no board apes done a bunch of
a lot of damage to our lobbying because I'm trying to get people to take crypto seriously
and all I'm getting is static about overpriced monkey jpegs right like him
yeah in the space the sounds weird outside of the space I mean mirage is not outside of the space
right he's a deep crypto person he's and he was like oh gosh this hurts my lobbying yeah
for this one I said well it doesn't seem like it'd be that hard to explain that TFPs are
thing and they'll be expensive ones and inexpensive ones and factors hundreds of thousands
of inexpensive ones so like why is this a big deal but it does seem to bother people and I've
noticed them the last couple of years that I've been active one of the things although I can't
believe people paid this much for a cartoon this is a joke to scam it's a bubble there's that
so there's that kind of bucket and then there's I think a much narrower bucket that
there are folks who say you know does the collection reinforce stereotypes about different
ethnicities and is that a problem what's your view on these two topics so in regards to your
second question there I think I was clear earlier on when I said
we really see board ape as an homage to a lot of the personalities that we engage with on
crypto twitter or follow it on crypto twitter years ago and it is such an affectionate term
that people have used for themselves as traders you know across crypto but also just across like
you know Web2 stock trading where you have AMC now coming out with a stock dividend ticker
and all that and so really that that's what this is about and we have always sought to create a club
that is extremely inclusive we were early on thought of almost more like we were getting deemed
on for being the care bears with the space with how like friendly our discord was as opposed to
say the punks discord early on and that's really important to us there are there's a playfulness
and an irreverence and some old school punk and hip hop traits and other things like that but it
is all in the spirit of just fun and inclusivity and we stand against hate in every way
as part of your other question yeah it's been interesting to see how certain
crypto people have not taken teneties whereas it feels like you said to be the ultimate product
market fit for the open metaverse and part of it I think I think Neurosh has also been a
worker too where he thinks the whole idea of like the metaverse is almost scamming itself
which is a bit nuts considering how much time we all spend in front of screens I think that's what
like you know I think biology put out a tweet yesterday about this that I thought was very apt
where you know what is Twitter if not a version of the metaverse people have digital
avatars and they're expressing themselves in the somewhat open system and that we are all spending
so much time in COVID-19 accelerated this in front of screens and so the idea of the metaverse
is just that we should be spending those that time in inherently open air-operable spaces the idea
is that a lot of the web-to- virtual experiences that we've had are maybe more akin to
the early internet than the current internet let's say there may be more akin to AOL where
everything exists inside of a box and it's trying to keep something that wants to be open closed
rather than something that's more open and if we can properly incentivize
monetization structures so that their community creators are being able to
derive value from what they're creating on a platform on a you know a blockchain platform
that's really special and that's going to change a lot of things people are already spending
billions of billions dollars a year on all kinds of different skins they're they're just not
NFTs League of Legends one of the most successful game companies world they spend you know people buy
like two billion dollars of you know jungle rat skins it's team of skins that like sell more than
anything else on that platform and so if you think of a boardade as just the nascent expression
of authenticity and scarcity and interoperability on the blockchain then I think you become a lot
closer to understanding how this can restructure certain industries so yeah it is a little heartbreaking
to hear from certain people who don't get it and whose job is to educate others and are so
incredibly flippant about the idea of getting an education or engaging more directly with creators
in crypto. Look I miss both of those making a lot of sense and on this point I couldn't agree
to do more I mean it was always my mind with a bunch of people who all day looking at a screen
with a bunch of avatars it just happens to me called Twitter and a lot of other people in centralized
games with characters and those same people are like oh I'm a pfp is on better versus practically
a scam you know like wait this is the better version of what you're doing right this is the actually
crypto native version of what you're doing this is literally the actual most likely use of
non custodial crypto for most people on the planet you should lean into it but we're not there
I believe my experience has been understanding bitcoin is kind of a zero to one experience
a theory of maybe like zero to one or half to one I think people a lot of people in bitcoin could
not get there with a theory but a lot of people did I do think NFT is our closer to a
not being in crypto and understanding bitcoin type experience than almost anything else
post bitcoin I think most people who understood bitcoin could get their heads around Ethereum even
if they didn't like it or Solana or Uniswap or what have you but NFTs some of my
oldest crypto friends and colleagues who are in absolute OGs and crypto own 50 different tokens
understand everything I spent six to twelve months harassing about NFTs before I could get
them to sort of mentally accept the model like what this is exact same thing as bitcoin it's
exactly the same concept it's just the same concept for non-frontal options so I'm with you it's
it's strange okay we mentioned games and you mentioned games at the beginning and you know
multiplayer universes let's talk about other side why don't you tell us what other side is I
think a lot of the audience will know but maybe put a couple senses that are getting for those
who don't and where are we where are we going what are we doing what are the goals on other side
absolutely so other side is a metaverse platform in development
Yuga is obviously involved but so is improbable an incredible tech company based out of the UK
we had an initial customer experience about a two months ago where we had 4500 concurrent users
in one space in one virtual space it was incredible we called it first trip
and the thesis here is really around the idea that the metaverse should be something that exists
on the blockchain that it should be open and interoperable and allow people to come
as they are as they want to be the most special video game trailer
I ever saw as a kid was the super smash brothers trailer where you had like
link Zelda but also Super Mario and Bowser and Kirby and so many other people all mashed together
in this world and that's close to our vision of what the metaverse can be except not just
enabled by the fact of Yuga owning certain IP in the same way Nintendo does but in the fact that
in a world where people are creating projects that are entirely public domain or CC0 or following
commercial rights models like the ones that we've extended to all of our projects at Yuga
then any game can be kind of like super smash brothers and it was really important to us too though
where we don't want this to be like any other web2 game it's just on a blockchain
hey it's just a NMO but the NFT you know every asset is NFT it needs to embrace certain aspects
of the metaverse that haven't been done before really and that's where having that extreme
density of users that's like what we showed on the first trip is is very integral to how we want
people and experience the metaverse we want there to be more interaction there's a lot of big
companies out there that have visions for the metaverse obviously Facebook rebranded to meta
I don't want to speak for anyone else but I think the vision there is very
hardware driven you know if there's a lot about VR and perhaps in the future AR that people
are thinking about in the metaverse whereas our vision of the metaverse is a space where
just the social engagement and where we want to spend our time in digital spaces is what's
the most important and as somebody who grew up playing MMORPGs like every quest or Star Wars
Galaxy's or World of Warcraft there are games with absolutely atrocious graphics and frankly not
much better UI or UX and you know we were running on 56k modems where I have I had some of the most
important relationships in my life form on those platforms I have friends that met their significant
others and spouses playing MMO RPGs and I think when we have metaverse spaces where
that embrace a lot of the openness that we actually had more and more back then than we do nowadays
with you know how much more closed source certain games are that a lot of that potentiality
and that experience will open up and that that it's inherently better to build a metaverse
on the blockchain than it is not to and that's where feels like you can compete with absolute
giants where we are using a high-mind of of UDC creators to build on top of a platform
in a way where they will be able to retain the most value and so we will attract the best users
and other side is our bet on that where and in the same way where Warcraft 3 was a great game
super fun game what also had known all stars which spawned a whole industry on its own that was
like just creator made other side needs to be a fun game in its own right but also a platform for
creators to build on top of the idea of being in the same way that Warcraft 3 was you have to show
people the potential introduce them to a story engage them give them you know some emotional
an emotional stake in what's being built but also give them an incredible tool set to express
themselves on top of the platform and so with other side we fully intend on doing both of those
things and unlike a lot of different games where you get a trailer and then four years later
you get the game it's something that needs to be done in an iterative way where people can join
experience things along the way and give feedback and properly influence the creation of
the platform itself through different SDKs and toolkits and that sort of thing and so that's
that's the vision for other side so when do we get to go in I think I did that first
event convention but when when will we get you you've walked yourself into that question it's not
four years away when is it the persistent world will be coming in 2023 there will be multiple
experiences many multiple experiences along the way but the the initial kind of persistent world
where people will have you know full access to the initial customer experience will be in 2023
so the kind of true date failure point of most things that start off with the
logic that they're meta versus rather than games is user persistence right you see it on
the central end of the year there's a silly argument you want do they have 30 users they are
4,000 users they but whatever number it is it's very low at 4,000 it's not a big number right so
even if the central ends right about their numbers they're low and then there was the Wall Street
Journal article a couple days ago about meta where the biggest social media company in the world
and there you know people came they checked it out they didn't go back right and the concurrency
of them problems very impressive but the general failure mode of these types of things as you
come you look at it's oh wow it's really beautiful I see this with a 65 tonight museum district
people come and say oh wow look there's a massive museum and he did a great job displaying
generative NFTs and then okay I mean I don't know people are busy with all their lives and
we're not gonna come back and looking at every day for the same reason you don't go to the
mob every day right people have a life to live conceptually I understand that he is people
have their land and so and the tool kits without developed things and you're hoping the community
develops interesting things and I'll throw one more out there Tim Cook I think again today was
saying look it's not going to be this type of stuff it's going to be augmented reality of the
type of like you know you're gonna be living in your day-to-day life you'll have this cool apple
glasses I guess next year and I think I'm reading into it you know you'll have app-like
functionality you know directions or recipes or I know dinosaurs running around your house or
something something along those lines what is going to bring people back into these because
I notice like always checking my own usage right and I definitely spend more time on Twitter
and in discord than it all means it's not even closer now and until that changes it means
the model's not right because for all of this we're going to build decentralized open
metaphors well I'm on two centralized platforms most of the day and most of the time that I'm not
on those centralized platforms I'm an outlocking Gmail and Microsoft offers and Windows which are
also centralized platforms so how do we move real screen time off the centralized platforms into
these blockchain-based platforms yeah no it's a great point and obviously one that we think
about all the time as well number one I think it needs to be easy to jump in and jump out you need
to be able to click a button somebody links to you on Twitter and whether you're on your computer
or your own phone you should be able to get inside and in one click that's something that is
being built into how we that's how other side will function at the same time it's important
also think about like the way that how do successful games even the ones like you know you or I
would have grown up playing like really dense virtual worlds with stories and fun what drove us
to spend tons of time there for me it was a few things number one there was a story there was
a game a core game loop that was engaging and it forced collaboration if you think about I played
a ton of legal legends in my life I have never made a friend play that game I blocked tons of
people that say talk to things and are trolls on thing but I've never made a friend on the
web I have played legal legends friends but their friends I made playing a request or will work
after something else because in those traditional and the most there is a reward very tangible reward
frankly for interacting with other people the only reason you make a friend in the metaverse is
because you're getting your aspect like if you need to slay the dragon and you can do it on your
own and it's like step off dude this is my loop but if you have that kind of force collaboration
that incentivizing it then that opens up the space for some of those relationships to form
but do you actually spend all your time in a metaverse actually going off and slaying dragons and
and playing these game loops if it's anything like the games that you know I'm talking about
no you actually spend a lot of time in guild chat or in the marketplace or the bizarre looking for
items or setting up shop or doing kind of more relaxed things and so I think it's a lot about
you know these are things that we're constantly thinking about is you need to
reward people for collaborating make it so they have to talk to people and engage with people
and have fun doing that and then you also need to create the spaces where it's can be
the living room couch or the internet where you can just hang out with people in the same way
that a lot of people are using Twitter and discord to this day and so if you're not building with
those two things at the forefront then yeah I think it's your destined to fail because even those
two things are very difficult to pull off yeah I think it's going to be an incredible decade of
experimentation I don't think anyone's nailed it yet I mean there's very successful games that
have effectively become metaverses I don't think anyone has started with the word metaverse
and gotten an experience really right because if you did it would be a twitter sized
company a Facebook size company right like you would spend all our time all right let's wrap
up with the punks in first quarter last year you debought the IP of the punks and the Mibits but
I think people care more about the punks and the larval abs punks and Mibits and beyond this being
like utterly shocking 21 who was there a year less than a year after the mid right I mean if you
could have taken odds nine months earlier one of the odds that not only the board aches the
punks but then by the punks and I think people would have given you a million to what odds right
like it's the most improbable thing that happened in the last 24 months and it was very interesting
because the even though the punks had this image of decentralization there actual license terms
as far as anyone could tell or fairly centralized and I say as far as anyone could tell because the
larval abs founders are absolute geniuses but didn't communicate very much so a lot of people
just guessing what they were thinking and this is what I think got 4156 subset with them at the end
that and he sold his his ape and so you move the punks to the commercial rights model which
objectively is a more decentralized model than that before there's no question about that it's
objectively more decentralized and I thought that was very good but also a lot of OG punks holders
didn't feel nice they felt disillusioned they and if you dug out it what was the thing that was
bothering them it felt like a corporate thing that happened you say well but you know it's just
as corporate before as it is now it was owned by one company outside by a different company and
this company is more open and I think I'm putting words in their mouth but I think this is actually
how it is there was a state of suspended disbelief before but like because the founders were very
much absent and I think in a way mostly people could just project onto the punks you know it's
an OG and it's an OG message and it's a message of crypto and decentralization and then the
crystallization of well that he was owned by a company now it's a bit of a company I think to
some some of the OG punks I don't think they loved it I mean if you know those like a mixed
reaction I was on the more positive of the group but I think some of the more OGs were less
but there's a lot of people in weight and c-mode I think like seeing like okay what will what will
happen now with all that how do you view the punks how do you view the punks in your broader
extended universe how is there your stewardship how's their pathway might be different than
the board apes what does this all mean how should how should the punks community think about
the topic from your perspective yeah absolutely it's different it's completely different then
crypto punks is very different from board API club and so are the communities and
and the projects should be treated extremely differently because of that our
vision of crypto punks has always been that they are like the Mona Lisa of NFTs the early cave
paintings of NFTs they are these originals that should they be treated with respect and
good stewardship will always flourish and that our job is to do just that that what's good for
punks is good for apes and what's good for apes is good for punks that's why frankly we wanted to
own them rather than someone else who might because we felt like we understood that you know if
it something bad were to happen a punks it wouldn't be good for apes and the only reason
we felt like we could acquire them that there was a path forward here was if we were going to as
you say decentralize the IP with a full commercial license in the vein of what we did for BUIC
that felt to us just to be objectively better for punk holders and something that we felt like
was being asked for for a while we're at least clarity around it and so we have taken a slow
approach here and hope to continue to do so in a way that is in active communication with
punk holders I know Noah meets with punks all the time and we want to act in a way that aligns
with the majority vision where we can do things like restore the crypto punks app marketplace where
there are things that aren't quite working as intended or as they should and they can be spruced
up and fixed a bit of retouching to the monolith as it were but you know at most a new frame and not
a drastic change of that so that's kind of the broad vision for how we how we view punks
like that makes sense it makes sense to me I think on the whole the punks don't need very much their
social construction will happen naturally and like most I spoke to Noah and I was trying to think
of ideas and like I think a lot of ideas and I'm like yeah most of ideas are actually bad like I'm
not going to say anything like like most ideas probably are negative but the median idea one
could think of to do with the punks probably is not helpful to the punks right and so it takes a
very I think delicate touch to see how that can be distorted without breaking because the punks I
think are I think what it is because there's so low res people can project whatever they want on
them and to the degree they become more physically insatiated they think they take more physical form
it might break the take my image of what six five to nine means right whereas I have a board
I have multiple board eights of mutants and I have those they're much more detailed so my
image and your image of what my board eight look like are probably pretty close because they're
much more detailed whereas like what I envision when I look at six five to nine and when you're
envision when I look at those and what no envision is it might be totally different and most of the
people have made for me all these like 3d versions of my punks and I've almost without
exception came over what I hate them I hate them look at them I'm like ah that's not how and I
can't tell you what I envision it but it's not bad what action vision is this low res
you know that it's more of a blank slate okay well I have gone way over time and you have
very generous with your time I'm going to give you the floor for one more topic what question should
I have asked I didn't what should we have covered that we didn't what's the closing words
you'd like to leave for the group question that you should have asked but you didn't I don't know
I wish we got to talk more about you know memes and shitposts or something like that
some of these like that Twitter briarality that that's actually so core to crypto but you know
for another day what we'll see is the memes production another day but you do that in the
spring semester sounds great okay well thank you so thank you so much this was great and I think
the students will get a ton out of this thank you so much for having me thanks for hosting
thank you